♪
>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
HILL'S JOHN SOLOMON.
THE HILL REPORTING TONIGHT
NEW INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION HAS BEEN
LOOKING FOR ANY POSSIBLE
WRONGDOING SURROUNDING
PLAY-TO-PLAY OR OTHER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY WHILE
HILLARY CLINTON WAS SERVING
AS YOURSELVES.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE DAILY
BEAST REPORTING THE DOJ IS
LOOKING INTO HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER.
JOHN SOLOMON, SARA CARTER
WILL JOIN NEWS A MINUTE.
HERE WITH REACTION TO THE
SHOCKING NEWS AS WELL AS
TONIGHT'S OPENING MONOLOGUE
IS THE FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
SEBASTIAN GORKA.
AND FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT
AT LARGE APPARENTLY CO-HOST
OF THE FIVE NOW GERALDO
WEEK.
THIS IS HUGE NEWS.
THEY ARE NOW LOOKING INTO
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AND
IT'S NOW CONFIRMED.
THEY ARE NOW ARE CLEARLY
ALSO NOW LOOKING INTO THE
EMAIL SERVER SCANDAL WHICH
WE NOW KNOW COMEY BASICALLY
RIGGED WITH PETER STRZOK
BECAUSE THEY WROTE AN
EXONERATION MONTHS BEFORE
THE INVESTIGATION.
>> I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
EMAIL SCANDAL, THERE IS NO
DOUBT BUT THAT THE FIX WAS
IN.
IT IS ALSO AN ARE A
CHARACTER SCANDAL AND IF WE
GO BACK THERE AGAIN THE EYES
OF THE PUBLIC WILL ROLL BACK
IN THE HEAD WHAT'S NEXT
BENGHAZI?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT CRIME IT
WOULD BE.
YOU NEED INTENT TO VIOLATE
ACCESS AND DESTROY IT,
BLEACH BIT IT, ACID WASH IT.
FOR PLAY CLINTON FOUNDATION
ASPECT OF THIS IS MUCH MORE
INTRIGUE SOMETHING THAT IT
THREADED AND HOURS AND HOURS
YOU MORE THAN MOST, BUT I
WANT TO KNOW HOW THE
CLINTONS BECAME SO WEALTHY
WHEN THEY NEVER HAD A REAL
IF YOU CONFLATE THIS WITH
URANIUM.
RING, BRIBERY EXTORTION,
MONEY LAUNDERING KICK BACKS,
SEBASTIAN.
THEY STILL ALLOWED CFIUS TO
BACK TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION $150 MILLION,
THE RULE OF LAW AND NOW
MILLER IS GOING TO FIND OUT
THE ANSWER TO HER OWN
QUESTION WHAT DIFFERENCE
DOES IT MAKE?
AND GERALDO I DIDN'T KNOW
YOU STUDIED LAW, I WILL HAVE
TO TELL YOU SOMETHING AS
FORMER FEDERAL EMPLOYEE
INTENT IS IRRELEVANT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS IN
THAT INFORMATION TO A
FOREIGN AGENT.
IF YOU SIMPLY MISPLACE IT,
YOU HAVE COMMITTED A FELONY.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW ASPECTS
OF FEDERAL LAW WHERE INTENT
IS IRRELEVANT.
AND THAT WOMAN HAD AT LEAST
1088 EMAILS AT THE HIGHEST
PRIVATE SERVER.
THAT'S A FELONY, GERALDO.
>> THIS IS THE WAY I TOTALLY
DISAGREE WITH YOUR LEGAL
ANALYSIS.
>> IT'S A FACT, GERALDO.
>> I MAKE A MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT POINT.
I CARE ABOUT THE 45TH
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
I CARE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
I WANT HIS PRESIDENCY TO BE
A SUCCESS.
I FEAR THAT HE IS NOT
TOUTING HIS STRENGTH AS SEAN
THAT IS INCLUDING EVERYBODY
FROM THE WEALTHY TO THE
PERSON THE URBAN PERSON.
>> SO HILLARY GETS A PASS?
>> Sean: BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT
SEVEN-YEAR LOW.
>> I WANT TO TOUT THAT
SUCCESS.
I WANT TO SCREAM THAT FROM
THE ROOFTOPS THAT POSITIVE
MESSAGE IS WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE YEARNING WHO HEAR
NOT HILLARY CLINTON EMAILS
AND EQUAL JUSTICE.
>> Sean: EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
>> IS THE STATUE OF LADY
JUSTICE BLINDFOLDED FOR A
REASON, GERALDO?
ALL AMERICANS SHOULD BE
EQUAL BEFORE THE LAW.
WHETHER WHETHER YOUR LAST
NAME IS RIVERA OR WHETHER
FELONIES, IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING.
THE FACT THAT DID.
>>
IT DOES NOT GOWITHOUT SAYING.
CAN YOU NOT MAKE A STATEMENT
LIKE THAT BECAUSE YOU ARE A
SMART MAN.
>> THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
SAID SHE HAD 108 CLASSIFIED
EMAILS ON HER PRIVATE
SERVER.
THAT'S A FELONY, GERALDO.
>> AND IN THE LAST 2, 3
YEARS WHY HASN'T THERE BEEN
ANY MEANINGFUL.
>> THE FIX WAS IN.
>> THAT'S NOT THE QUESTION.
>> Sean: HANG ON A SECOND.
>> DO YOU WANT DONALD TRUMP
TO BE DRAGGED BACK INTO THAT
CRAP AGAIN.
>> Sean: IT'S NOT DONALD
I ASK YOU THIS, WHY WOULD
COMEY AND STRUCK, A TRUMP
HATER, BE WRITING, HANG ON,
EXONERATION MONTHS BEFORE
THEY EVER EVEN INTERVIEWED
THE MAIN PEOPLE INVOLVED?
>> WITH DOZENS OF HOSTILE
EYES ON HILLARY CLINTON'S
99% CERTAINTY FIVE FOREIGN
AGENCIES HAD ACCESS TO THAT
NEXT QUESTION.
SO YOU ARE TELLING ME IT'S
NOT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
IF I HAVE SUBPOENAED EMAILS,
33,000 I DELETE, HANG ON,
THEN I ACID WASH AND BLEACH
BLACKBERRIES AND I SMASH
THEM WITH A HAMMER.
YOU ARE NOT TELLING ME
>> I AM TELLING YOU THAT.
>> Sean: TRUE OR FALSE.
>> EVEN AS YOU RECITED THAT
WITH YOUR ELOQUENCE, MY EYES
ROLLED, WHY?
BECAUSE I DON'T CARE ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON.
YOU CARE ABOUT EQUAL
JUSTICE.
>> I CARE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT SUCCEEDING AND
UNITING THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: HE IS NOT GOING TO
>> EVERY AMERICAN, GERALDO
INCLUDED, SHOULD CARE IF
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN HILLARY CLINTON WAS
COUNSEL.
AND THE FBI, NOT HILLARY,
THE FBI DESTROYED THE
LAPTOPS THAT WERE CENTRAL TO
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THAT
MEANS WE HAVE GOT BAD COPS.
>> I CARE ABOUT THE FUTURE
NOT THE PAST.
>> WHAT IF THE CRIME WAS
MITTED AGAINST YOUR DAUGHTER
10 YEARS AGO, WOULD YOU CARE
ABOUT THAT PERSON.
>> IF YOU SHOW ME ONE VICTIM
FROM THAT WHOLE EMAIL
BOLOGNA, THEN I WILL AGREE.
>> Sean: AMERICA'S NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> AMERICA.
>> Sean: FOREIGN AGENTS
PICKED UP ON IT, GERALDO.
>> LIKE WHAT, A CIA DOCUMENT